We're going to tell you about the chemistry for all snake.
My goodness.
It's a fascinating element.
Very poisonous.
Compounds murders have been carried out with it.
It has some very nice connections with ancient wallpaper.
And Neil is going to show you a whole series of experience.
The books say that our snake looks metallic,
but our sample looked a bit Brown.
So Neil heated it in a test tube. I'll snakes.
Interesting. It doesn't melt it. Sublimes when you heat it.
That is the vapor is formed and condenses on the side of the
vessel. And if you look carefully,
you can see it makes a very nice metallic film often called an
arsenic mirror. Arsenic is particularly famous as a poison.
People used it to get rid of their lovers, their waves,
or just go with people.
And the compound they used is arsenic oxide,
ASMR four Oh six. Now we didn't have a sample of this.
So we decided that Neil would make some forests.
So he began by dissolving our snake in dilute nitric
acid.
There's quite a violent reaction, lots of bubbling.
And it forms the gas and nitric oxide,
which is colorless,
but it reacts with air to give nitrogen dioxide,
which is Brown.
So you can see Brown fumes coming out to the test tube.
The textbooks say that when you dissolve our snake in nitric acid,
you make a solution of the oxide.
We want the poisonous oxide it's meant taste of sugar.
Neil set up a very nice filter system, poured the solution in,
and it came through. I must say it did still look a little Brown,
but we were really hopeful. We were going to get our white powder.
The next stage of course is to go from solution to solid.
So you have to evaporate of the water.
It was a bit slow process.
I got bored and went out while Neil was finishing it.
What a disappointment instead of this lovely white powder,
there was some sticky Brown solid I presume because we've
still got some parts circles of our snake in the white powder.
At least we've tried,
but I still think it's probably our snake oxide.
The reason they used us, Nick oxide was they could easily get it.
It was a white powder. It tasted sweet.
So it wasn't very noticeable if you mixed it with sugar.
So our Brown stuff is not going to be much use for poisoning people.
Fortunately, we're not going to try.
I have two favorite stories about poisoning.
Both of them are true.
The first one happened in a town in the North of England called
Bradford. It happened in 1858 in October.
In those days, sugar was quite expensive.
So people who made sweets were very dishonest and added some
cheap powder to the sugar so that they didn't have to put so much sugar in the
sweets. They called this white powder daft on this particular occasion,
a sweet maker called John Neil,
sent his lodger to go and get some daft to put
in his next batch of sweets.
He called them lots of inches and he went to the next town
and went to a pharmacist.
And the pharmacist told his assistant to go and fetch the daft,
which was the white powder. And unfortunately he didn't explain correctly.
So the pharmacist so old 12 pounds,
that's five kilos of arsenic oxide to the
unfortunate customer.
This was mixed in with the sweet mixture and more than 20
people died of arsenic poisoning in Bradford and more than
200 were really ill.
And this was one of the things that led to greater control of our snake
in the United Kingdom.
The other case took place in the early 1920s
in a town in the West of England called Hayan why the
attacks were carried out by a solicitor,
a lawyer who in fact was the only lawyer who's ever been hanged in the
UK.
It is believed he poisoned his wife with our snake over a period of
several months.
And then one of his business rivals was
invited to tea.
The lawyer passed a scone,
a little cake in his fingers to his rival. And as he passed it,
he said, excuse fingers. And in that moment,
it is believed he put our snake on the cake.
His guest was very ill and was found to have been poisoned with our
snake.
So they exhumed the body of his wife DocuTAP and it was full of
arsenic.
So he was tried and convicted and it's executed.
It should be said that he always denied that he had done this,
that when he was arrested,
he did have our Snick powder in the packet in his pocket.
Did he a good white powder or have Brown sludge? She had nice white powder.
The question is,
how did they find our snake in the body of his dead wife?
Who'd been under the ground for several months.
And it's with a very clever test that was invented in the early 19th
century called Marsh is test and Neil decided he would like to
do Marsh's test too.
The first thing you have to do is add metallic sync.
I was really excited. I was allowed to chop up the zinc.
You put in the pieces of sink into round bottom flask,
and then you add whatever you think contains arsenic.
In our case, a small amount of Neal's Brown sludge,
And then throw them a dropping funnel.
You drop in dilute sulfuric acid and the sulfuric
acid reacts with the zinc and generates hydrogen.
And the hydrogen reacts with the snake and makes a
compound, which has a similar formula to ammonia,
but it has three hydrogens attached to our snake rather than three
hydrogens are types to nitrogen, which you have in pneumonia.
And this compound called RCN is very volatile. It's a gas
As the hydrogen streams off the reaction, it takes the RC in with it.
You're then meant to light the stream of hydrogen coming out of the nozzle.
The top of the operators, if it's just hydrogen coming out,
it would be colorless.
And Brady was absolutely convinced that we would see a
colorless list flame,
and he could tell us how bad we'd been at the experiment.
Oh my goodness. It works. I can't believe it works.
That's amazing. Yes. You happy? Yes.
So the murderer is guilty Martin.
Much to all our surprise.
The flame came out a beautiful lavender color.
Lavender is the color that arsenic burns with,
but the real elegance of Marsh's test is that
if you put a cold surface,
a piece of glass or a piece of porcelain into the flame,
Our scene does not burn completely.
So you get a thin film of our snake on the surface.
The importance of this was that once the film's there,
it will stay there.
So it could be taken to court to be shown as a piece of evidence.
And you could say, look,
ask Nick came out of the woman's stomach or whatever the, um,
sample was that you had.
There's another completely different way that people in the 19th
century were poisoned by arsenic.
And that was from the green coloring.
The green pigment that was used in their wallpaper.
This green pigment is a copper salt called Sheila's green.
It is made by taking a solution of sodium Mehta last
night, which is colorless and dropping in copper sulfate.
I've done this reaction several times, but I haven't done it for a long time.
And I was really surprised quite how beautiful it is saying this
green solid forming
Green was used quite widely. This would have been fine. Except in those days,
people were really frightened of drafts and they used to close
all the windows and doors and have very stuffy rooms,
which were not very well heated. So particularly at night when they were asleep,
there was a lot of condensation and mold would grow on the wallpaper.
And so the mold growing on your wallpaper could create a gas
containing our snake,
which if you were laying asleep in this Ellis room over a period of just one
night would be enough to kill you.
In October 18, 15,
Napoleon Bonaparte was brought a prisoner to the Island of Santalina in the
South Atlantic. Yeah. He was to spend the last six years of his life. Yeah.
He died on the 5th of May.
1821 examination was made of specimens of hair syndrome being taken from the
head of Napoleon before and after he died,
the results establish the presence of arsenic.
My friend, David Jones,
who was an expert in really weird chemical facts,
wondered whether the stories of Napoleon being poisoned with
arsenic by the weekly British could in fact be due to mold on the
wallpaper, in his house, on the Island of St. Halina,
where he was exiled.
And remarkably David managed to get hold of a sample of
Napoleon's wallpaper, which had some green marks on it.
And he could analyze this and show that it did indeed contain
arsenic.
And there was enough arsenic in Napoleon's wallpaper to explain the arsenic
that had been found in his hair,
but not enough to kill him.
So according to David's experiments,
the British did not poison Napoleon,
but he just felt unwell because of his green wallpaper.
The action of mold on arsenic compound was
exploited for real chemistry by an
Australian chemist called Bruce wild and his technician,
Paul Gungan, they did a really unique experiment.
They got some bread and injected it with an arsenic
compound that was not volatile.
And then put the bread in a large container and let mold grow
on it. The mold converted the arsenic compound into
volatile compound gas. Then they led this through to,
into a solution and they got a yellow solution of a new complex.
And the reason they use the mold is because unlike human chemists,
the mold could produce a so-called optically active
compounds.
That is a left-handed version of the molecule without the right handed one.
Whereas ordinary cameras produced both at the same time and they
published a great paper and they had an extraordinary photo
of Paul,
the technician holding this loaf of bread full of arsenic.
I dread to think what their safety assessment looked like.
This piece of metal has an extraordinary story about it,
which involves arsenic. When I first came here to Nottingham,
one of my colleagues,
Mike was studying the reactions of our snake with liquid
fluorine. If it's done carefully,
this is a nice controlled reaction.
You have to do it with the operators cooled in liquid nitrogen.
So he was doing the reaction inside the thermos flask that looks
like this,
and something went wrong and there was an enormous explosion.
All that was left of the thermals was the plastic top.
And this piece of metal, everything else was distributed around the lab.
But I think the importance of this is to show you that our snake,
if you get it in the right state,
or perhaps I should say the wrong state can react very violently.
I went into the lab before it had been cleaned up and this,
because I was just so amazed by it.
And I used to use it when I was teaching about arsenic chemistry.
Apparently Metallica,
Nick can occasionally be found in natural minerals,
but usually it's found as compounds. And in our store, we have a sample of,
one of the minerals containing our snake. That's called [inaudible]
. It's an arsenic sulfide, which has really very nice red crystals. Unfortunately, as sample has rather small crystals.
But if you look at the Mandarin
microscope, you can see really nice red crystals, which are of arsenic sulfite
. And this is probably why ask Nick compounds when then
even in ancient times, because of these brightly colored minerals, while we were filming, Neil found some amazing old papers,
led acetate papers for testing for arsenic
. They were labeled 20th of July, 1942 before any of us were born. So we tried these papers out, tried testing them on some of
Neil's mixtures that had made We're
expecting the papers to go black. However, Nothing much happened. We haven't thrown them away because one of you may know how to use these papers, or we may find out some instructions.
And because Martin doesn't.
Throw anything away.
It is said that our arsenic was discovered by a German Bishop called
Albertus Magnus,
who is buried in the city of cologne in Germany. And about a year ago,
I gave a lecture in cologne and the students took me to see his
grave.
And they made a couple of little videos of me looking at it,
not as professional as Brady or James, but still quite fun.
[Inaudible].
Albertus,
Magnus has real significance in cologne to
current PhD students.
There is a tradition that when they graduate successfully,
when they finish their doctorate,
they go to his statue and they touch his thumb is a sign of good
luck for the future career.
[Inaudible].